HERE WE GO.
DELICIOUS DELICIOUS WATER.
HAPPY THURSDAY, EVERYONE PICKED
LET'S GET INTO THE HOLIDAY
SPIRIT AND BOMB MEXICO.
HEAR ME OUT.
IT'S NOT REALLY ABOUT MEXICO.
IT'S ABOUT FENTANYL IT'S KILLIN
OUR NATION'S YOUNGEST PEOPLE
LIKE CRAZY, MORE THAN 75% WITH
AN ADOLESCENT OVERDOSE TEST
YEARS WERE FENTANYL POISONINGS
ON OVERDOSES SCHOOLS ARE LOADIN
UP ON NARCAN AND MUCH LIKE BRIA
KILMEADE'S BOOK, YOU CAN GET IT
FREE AT VENDING MACHINES IT JUS
CAUSES YOU TO THROW UP.
IT'S AMAZING PICK BUT NARCAN IS
REALLY A BAND-AID FOR CRISIS
THAT IS HEMORRHAGING LIVES PICK
I CONTAIN THE DRUGS ARE BAD BUT
IT WON'T CHANGE ANYONE'S MIND I
CAN IMAGINE MY TEENAGE SON
WATCHING --
AND THINKING I WANT NO PART OF
THAT.
I COULD CRACK AN EGG OVER A
SKILLET AT SAY THIS IS YOUR
BRAIN ON DRUGS, BUT I DON'T
SISTER TOOK TO GET.
YOU COME HERE FOR THE THOUGHTFU
COMMENTARY DELIVER 51
RIDICULOUSLY GOOD-LOOKING HOST
AT FOUR OTHER NORMAL PEOPLE.
SO THE FIRST STEP IN STOPPING
THE DRUG CRISIS IS TO ADDRESS
THE SUPPLY PICK IT'S HARD TO
TAKE OUT ALL CARTELS IN MEXICO
BOMB THE OUT OF THEM.
[APPLAUSE]
IT WILL BE OVER IN MINUTES.
THE PRESENCE OF OVENS BM LAST
LONGER.
AND IF THE OPERATION STARTS UP
SOMEWHERE ELSE, YOU BOMB THAT TO
.
CARTELS WOULD BE NO DIFFERENT
THAN MOWING THE LAWN AND A SHOR
TIME YOU'D BE SURPRISED
HOPEFULLY THE CARTEL MIGHT BE A
RECONSIDERING THEIR INVESTMENTS
IN FENTANYL.
THERAPIST THEIR BUSINESS BUT
AFTER ALL JUST CHANGE THE
BENEFITS RISK ANALYSIS BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW USING DRUGS ENTAILS
WAY MORE RISK THAN MAKING THEM.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS SUPPOSED TO B
EPIC CARTEL HEAD HAD NEVER
UNPACKED A SUITCASE OR FIGURE
OUT THAT WE ARE WHISTLING NOISE
FOR THE INCOMING WHISTLE, MAYBE
THEY WILL REASSESS THE FENTANYL
REVENUE STREAM NO BOMBING SEEMS
HARSH.
CONSIDERING THAT WE'VE INVADED
COUNTRIES NO LESS, REMEMBER
GRENADA IN 83, WE TURNED THAT
INTO A SANDALS RESORT AT ABOUT
SIX MINUTES AND CONCERN FOR 600
MEDICAL STUDENTS ON THE ISLAND
LOT OF THEM ARE SMOKING HOT
NURSES BUT THAT IS NOT MY POINT.
THAT IS NOTHING COMPARED TO THE
100,000 DEATHS EACH YEAR TIED T
CARTELS OR HOW ABOUT PANAMA IN
89.
WE BUT AFTER NORIEGA BECAUSE HE
WAS WANTED ON DRUG TRAFFICKING
SURE YOU WAS NOT CLEARASIL THAT
HE WAS PUSHING.
CHEAP SHOTS.
HOW ABOUT YUGOSLAVIA IN 99.
YOU REMEMBER THAT?
COINCIDENTALLY WHAT BILL CLINTO
GOT CAUGHT MISUSING CIGARS, IT
KILLED PEOPLE FOR LESS AND SO
WHEN PROTECTIVE CARTELS KILL
100,000 LINKS TO YOUR, HOW IS
THAT NOT ALREADY A WAR FOR IT
DOES NOT MATTER MEXICO WON'T
DEGREE WHEN THE CARTELS ARE FRE
TO INVADE US ANYWAY.
WE DID MISS PAKISTAN IF WE COUL
DROP IN AND KILL BIN LADEN SO
THAT TAKES CARE OF THE SUPPLY.
WHAT ABOUT DEMAND.
OR WE CAN SO EVERYONE'S NOSTRIL
SHUT THAT CUTS DEMAND BY ABOUT
80%.
REALLY WE HAVE TO FINALLY ADMIT
THAT THE DESIRE FOR RECREATIONA
OBLIVION IS BASICALLY UN- KILL
PULPIT DESPITE THE RISKS, DRUGS
FEEL GOOD TO PEOPLE AND THEY
PROVIDE AN ESCAPE WHAT ELSE WAS
THERE TO DO THERE UNTIL THEY HA
NETFLIX AND IF THEY DID THE
REACTION TO IT WOULD BE THE SAM
AS OURS IS TODAY, SCREW THIS,
I'M GOING TO SMOKE SOME DINOSAU
DROPPINGS THAT IS WHY THEY
DISAPPEARED.
WE KNOW LET LAWS WON'T CHANGE
THIS BEHAVIOR.
ALCOHOL JUST GOT THEIR FIRST.
SIMPLY ACCEPT IT, THE VEHICULAR
HOMICIDE AND A LIVER TRANSPLANT
SPIRIT WE ALL HAVE A RIGHT TO
RELIEF, ESPECIALLY ANYONE THAT
WORKS FOR THEM VIEW.
LEGALIZE DRUGS JUST FOR THAT
REASON PEOPLE WE KEEP RESPECT --
RESTRICTING PAIN RELIEVERS AND
THOSE DRUGS WILL COME WITH
DEADLY CRISPY KIDS ARE BUYING
THEM ALL.
THEY'RE TRYING OTHER THINGS,
WHICH ARE POISONED WITH THE
STUFF PAID SINCE THE TINIEST
AMOUNT IS SUPER LETHAL, IT'S
EASY TO SMUGGLE AND CHEAPER TO
USE AS AN INGREDIENT AND THE LA
WON'T STOP IT UNLESS IT'S LINED
WITH ARMED SOLDIERS.
YOU COULD THROW A LETHAL BUNDLE
RIGHT OPERATE UNLESS YOU ARE DR.
POUCH HE.
I FIGURED WE NEEDED A LAUGHED --
A LAUGH RIGHT THERE.
AFTER FINDING THEM TANGLED IN
HER NIECES HAIR.
OR DISGUSTING BUT FENTANYL IS
EASY TO SMUGGLE BECAUSE THE
BLOCK THE SIZE OF A SNICKERS
COULD FLATTEN CALIFORNIA.
NOT A BAD IDEA.
I'M KIDDING, I STILL HAVE FAMIL
THERE FOR NOW.
SO THAT IS --
REDUCE DEMAND AND PROVIDE SAFER
ALTERNATIVES AND THAT GIVES US
FIGHTING CHANCE BECAUSE WE'VE
LOST THE WAR ON DRUGS SO NOW
IT'S TIME TO SAVE SOME LIVES.
>> WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
FOR CHRISTMAS THIS YEAR HER KID
WANTED TO DRINK WATER APPEARED
FOX NEWS ANCHOR AT AUTHOR OF TH
CHILDREN'S BROOK --
BOOK.
[APPLAUSE]
HE TAKES SOME LIBERAL POLICIES
AND ISSUES ZERO APOLOGIES.
OR NEW YORK CONGRESSMAN.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND HE CONSIDERS SANTA'S
REINDEER A HIGH-PROTEIN
BREAKFAST.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK IN THE WNBA
WORLD TELEVISION SHAPE SHIP.
>> FIRST OF FALL, CONGRESSMAN,
CONGRATULATIONS ON A HEROIC
CAMPAIGN.
YOU BROUGHT US ALMOST THERE BUT
YOU BROUGHT SOME RED TO NEW YOR
AND THAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
IT'S GOING TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM
LEAVING NEW YORK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT BOMBIN
MEXICO.
CAN I ANSWER THE FIRST QUESTION.
TIMES HAVE CHANGED.
THE CLOSEST THING WITH THAT
GENERATION IS TRYING TO GET MY
HANDS ON BASEBALL CARDS AND
CANDY.
THE HARDEST PART OF SERVING AS
MEMBER OF CONGRESS IS GOING TO
SOME WEIGHT, SOME YOUNG BOY OR
SOME YOUNG MEN BECAUSE OF THIS.
AND WE NEED TO BE TACKLING THIS
HEAD-ON WE TALK ABOUT OUR BORDER
, WE TALKED ABOUT THE
CONTEXT OF PEOPLE AND NOT SO
MUCH THINGS YOU BROUGHT UP A
POINT THAT YOU TALK ABOUT
FINISHING THE WALL AND THAT IS
ONE ASPECT OF SECURITY THAT IS
IMPORTANT, SUPPORTING OUR BORDE
PATROL AGENTS PER REMAIN IN
MEXICO POLICY AND INCENTIVIZING
AND AVOIDING LEGAL ENTRY WOULD
HELP PICK THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM
JOE BIDEN HASN'T EVEN BEEN TO
THE BORDER AND THAT IS HOW
THINGS ARE COMING ACROSS AS WEL
THIS STUFF IS SO TINY, IT'S SO
TINY.
THE BABY IN SAN FRANCISCO PICKS
UP BUT TINY ROCK IN THE NEXT
THING YOU KNOW SHE'S UNCONSCIOU
AND ALMOST DIES I GET YOU WOULD
HAVE TO HAVE GUARDS FOR AS FAR
AS YOU CAN SEE SO SHOULD WE BOM
MEXICO?
THAT'S WHAT I'M GETTING AT.
>> I'M NOT A BIG FAN OF THE
BOMBING OF MEXICO I'M A MILITAR
GUY AND I'M IN THE 20th YEAR
AND IN THE ARMY, THE IDEA OF US
WE OURS THAT STRETCHED AS IT IS.
THERE'S ALL SORTS OF ISSUES
IMPACTING MORALE AND OTHERWISE.
I DON'T THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE
STARTING OVER A WAR IN MEXICO.
>> I THINK THAT THERE ALREADY I
AN ACTIVE FOR.
AND ALSO 86.3% OF VEGETABLE
TRAFFICKING CONNECTIONS ARE
UNITED STATES THIS FITS SORRY
THAT RUINED EVERYBODY'S PARTY.
>> BUT WHERE IS IT COMING FROM.
>> HERE IS MORE STAT SPIRIT 0.2
OF THOSE ARRESTED AT BORDER
PATROL HAD FENTANYL ON THEM.
IT'S EASY TO LEGALLY BRING THEM
OVER THE BORDER SORTS WHERE THE
PEOPLE ARE BRINGING IT OVER THE
BORDER MY POINT IS WHERE IT IS
BEING MADE, THE CARTELS OF THE
PEOPLE IN CONTROL.
BOMB THEM AS WERE MANY PEOPLE
MIGHT HAVE AN ISSUE.
>> I DON'T.
I DON'T.
WE KNOW WHO YOU ARE AND WE ARE
GOING TO BOMB YOU PROJECT 50-20
MINUTES TO GET YOUR STUFF OUT
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO WITH THE
DRESS CARTELS AS THOUGH THEY AR
BUSINESS.
RIGHT NOW THEY NEED A
DISINCENTIVE, NOT AN INCENTIVE
TO DO FENTANYL PICK IF YOU WANT
TO DO MATH, DO MATH.
IF YOU WANT TO DO COKE, DO COKE
SO THAT MEANS 100,000 PEOPLE,
THEY STOP AT THAT.
THE POINT IS YOU HAVE TO DISTAN
VENT DIVIDES THE BUSINESS.
>> DISINCENTIVE BUYS THE
BUSINESS, SURE.
YOU CAN GET WHATEVER YOU WANT
AND KNOW EXACTLY WHAT YOU ARE
GETTING AND I'M STILL NOT GOING
TO DO HEROIN BECAUSE THE REASON
I DON'T DO IT IS NOT BECAUSE IT
IS ILLEGAL IN MANY PEOPLE SAY
THAT WAY.
LSU GUYS ARE JUST LOOKING FOR
HEROIN.
>> BECAUSE THAT THAT IS THE CASE
, ALL TELL YOU ABOUT A
DOUBLE SECOND I'M RUNNING.
>> YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH BEING
BOMBED, JULIE.
>> I DO NOT BELIEVE BOMBING
MEXICO IN THAT REGARD IS RIGHT
THERE IT'S A GOOD THING YOU HAV
NEVER RUN FOR OFFICE.
I DON'T SEE --
IT IS AN ACT OF WAR.
PEOPLE WOULD DIE AND MOST LIKEL
IN THE SENSE --
I'M JUST SAYING.
>> I THINK THAT IS KIND OF
IMPOSSIBLE.
OF COURSE WE DID.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
WE ARE SO SMART.
BUT I ALSO SAY JUST LIKE THE
DRUG EPIDEMIC IN THIS COUNTRY
COME IT IS SO BAD AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT A LOT OF IT IS
COMING OVER THE BORDER AND
OBVIOUSLY OUR BORDERS ARE NOT
CLOSE LIKE THE WHITE HOUSE
MAINTAINS THEY ARE PICK IF YOU
LOOK AT DRUGS IN GENERAL, IF YO
LEGALIZE DRUGS AND THEY WOULDN'
BE THAT BIG A FIVE PROBLEM I'M
CONCERNED THAT MARIJUANA WAS
LEGALIZED AS A SIDENOTE AND MOR
AND MORE PEOPLE ARE SMOKING POT
ARE TAKING EDIBLES AS YOUNG AS
THE AGE OF 6-18.
YOU SAW THAT STUDY.
SINCE WHEN DID PARENTS BECOME
SUCH LOSERS BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT THE PARENTS IN THIS COUNTR
ARE DROPPING THE BALL AND I
BELIEVE A LOT OF THIS THAT HAS
TO DO WITH KIDS THAT ARE
DABBLING IN DRUGS PICK IF THERE
IS THAT SMELL, YOU DIE.
THAT APPEARS DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
RESPECTED AS.
>> LAST WORD.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT BEING
AGGRESSIVE, TALK TO ME FIRST.
BECAUSE YOUR FOUR YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO BOB PICK BUT WE ARE
GOING TO TARGET SOME VERY BAD
PEOPLE.
DO YOU SEE WHAT I AM SAYING?
>> DO YOU SEE WHAT I DID RIGHT
THERE?
>> I AM NOT GOING TO BEAT THE
CAMERAMAN UP.
I AM GOING TO TALK TO HIM IT IS
ALL IN HOW YOU SAY IT YES, GREG
I AM TARGETING CARTELS WITH YOU
AND I THINK YOUR POINT IS STRON
AND VALID.
WHEN YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO
SAYS I TO DO THEN DEAL WITH THE
BORDER, THAT IS WHAT WE'RE WE
ARE UP AGAINST.
AND ALSO CONSEQUENCES.
IF BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
CONSEQUENCES AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ANYMORE, IF LITTLE JOHNNY WENT
OUT TO GET, I DON'T KNOW,
SOMETHING TO KEEP HIM UP ALL
NIGHT AND THEY ACTUALLY HAD
FENTANYL IN THEM AND THE FACT
THAT THE PRINT AND GOT HIM
KICKED OFF THE FOOTBALL TEAM IN
THE NEXT THING IS AS FRIENDS GO
I'M GOOD TO GO SCORE SOME --
NO, NO, NO, I WILL GET YOU
SUSPENDED OR I WILL GET EXPELLE
OR I WILL LOSE THIS EARTH THAT.
THERE'S NO CUT ACCOUNTABILITY
ANYMORE PICKED WE'VE GOT TO GET
BACK THE ACCOUNTABILITY.
SCHOOLS HAVE TO BE SCHOOLS AGAIN
.
SCHOOLS RUN SCHOOLS.
WE NEED THE RULES BACK UP YOUR
REMEMBER TARGETING.
>> BUT THEN MY MONOLOGUE
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN THAT MUCH BU
IF I SAID SHOULDN'T WE TARGET
MEXICO.
>> AND THE CROWD WOULD HAVE GON
YES, WE SHOULD.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I LEARNED A VALUABLE LESSON.
>> NO COMMIT YOU TO.
>> I DIDN'T.
>>